so you did mention physics as the the
first starting point so
um
general relativity allows for wormholes
uh they technically can exist do you
think
those can ever be leveraged by humans to
travel fast in the speed of light
well
are you saying the whole thing is
debatable uh the
that we currently do not know of any
means of going faster than the speed of
light
there is like
like
there are some ideas about
having space like so so
you can only move at the speed of light
through space but
if you can make space itself move
that that's like that that's
warping space
um
space is is capable of moving faster
than the speed of light
right
uh like the universe in the big bang the
universe expanded at much much more than
the speed of light
by a lot yeah um
so
um
but the
if this is possible the the amount of
energy required 12 space is so
gigantic it's boggles the mind
so all the work you've done with
propulsion how much innovation is
possible with rocket propulsion is this
um
i mean you've seen it all and you're
constantly innovating in every aspect
how much is possible like how much can
you get 10x somehow is there something
in there in physics
that you can get significant improvement
in terms of efficiency of engines and
all those kinds of things
well as i'm saying like the
really the holy grail is a fully and
rapidly reusable orbital system um so
uh right now uh
the
falcon 9 is the only reusable rocket out
there that but it but
the the booster comes back and lands and
you've seen the videos uh and we get the
nose conor faring back but we do not get
the upper stage back
so
uh
that means that we have a minimum cost
of
building an upper stage um
you can think of like a two-stage rocket
of sort of like two airplanes like a big
airplane and a smaller airplane
um and we get big airplane back but not
the smaller airplane and so it still
costs a lot you know so that upper stage
is
you know at least 10 million dollars
and then the
degree of the the booster is not as
reused it's not as rapidly and
completely reusable as we'd like in all
of the fairings
so
you know our kind of
minimum marginal cost not counting
overhead for per flight is on the order
of
15
to 20 million dollars maybe
um so
uh that's that's extremely good for
it's by far better than any rocket ever
in history um
but
uh
with full and rapid reusability we can
reduce the cost per ton to orbit by
uh a factor of a hundred
but just think of it like um
like imagine if you had an aircraft or
something or a a car
oh yeah and if you had to
buy a new car every time you went for a
drive it would be very expensive
it'd be silly frankly
but um
but you in fact you just refuel the car
or recharge the car
and that's uh makes your trip
like
i don't know a thousand times cheaper
so
it's the same for rockets uh if you look
it's
very difficult to make this complex
machine that can go to orbit
and so if you cannot reuse it and if you
have to throw even any part of any
significant part of it away that
massively increases the cost
so you know starship in theory could do
a cost per launch of like a million
maybe two million dollars or something
like that
um
and uh
and put over 100 tons in orbit
which is crazy yeah
so that's incredible so you're saying
like it's uh by far the biggest bang for
the buck is to make it fully reusable
versus like some kind of
brilliant breakthrough in theoretical
physics
no no there's no there's no brilliant
break no there's no
it just me you're gonna make the rocker
reusable this is an extremely difficult
ensuring problem
got it but no no new physics is required
you